this is texas experiencing an
unprecedented wildfire season and
america's hottest temperatures so far
this year
public libraries here are handing out
free water
offering a sanctuary and air
conditioning to the vulnerable
life-saving measures for those who are
homeless like richard how much tougher
is that being homeless in this sort of
weather
oh man it is tough it's tough especially
for an older person
this is like a sanctuary really for a
lot of people it's not just me you can
look around
a lot of homeless people are here right
now
the president is considering taking
executive action after his plans for
climate legislation were killed off in
congress last week this is an emergency
an emergency and i will i will look at
it that way i said last week and i'll
say it again loud and clear as president
i'll use my executive powers to combat
climate the climate crisis and the
absence of congressional action on the
weather stations we keep an eye on fort
worth has seen the country's highest
temperatures so far this year at 43
degrees celsius
experts say climate change is here we're
definitely seeing more extreme weather
due to climate change just overall it's
resulting in warmer and drier weather
across much of the southern united
states but of course we're seeing those
more extreme weather phenomena due to
climate change
texans have been asked to conserve water
and twice in the last week they've been
called on to limit their electricity use
as demand has got dangerously close to
overwhelming supply the nation's power
grid is under immense stress with people
across the country cranking up their air
conditioning and regulators are warning
that the sort of rolling blackouts that
are familiar to people here in texas and
in california could become far more
widespread as summers get hotter and
longer
america is one of the world's biggest
contributors to global warming yet
there's no climate policy to match the
conditions on the ground
sally lockwood sky news dallas texas